driver right
here get chose the driver yeah get away
come on
Miss 2 3 Sergeant
FAL
hello can you transport yourself need
sorry all right that's
fine I honestly don't know what happened
all right 1 2 3 so 13 driving straight
and
then that's about
it you talk yeah I was going I don't
know what
happened apparently they were pulling
out and I didn't see them I was just
going straight and apparent the car
flipped over I don't know what
happened sorry what is your name Raa
Risa yes uh Raa were you drinking
tonight I was earlier yeah yes when you
say you're earlier uh how much you're
earlier
uh
3:00 and how much did
you just stand by
here you're what feel soety mhm okay
take go up to the side the two of you
yes sir do what you do yes
sir you
uh give us a second we'll get it all
right Miss you're being placed under
arrest for driving while intoxicated
4-50
39450 okay
okay thank
you right
now
[Applause]
wait I'm only say that because I
have uh
I know it's it's not
[Applause]
FC driver right
here let's get away from the driver yeah
get away come on
Miss 1 2 3 Sergeant
FAL can youport
yourself sorry all right that's
fine who else is in the
car far just you y just me where were
you coming iemergency you take we're
going to need
you coming from green rock
yeah we got the driver right
here two three
just 134 over at 221 have them respond
to this
location 134 you copy
that this is my daughter this is my car
this
[Applause]
park
go
for all right disregard that 221 Jackson
I need your SP order 615 Bloomfield six
in Bloomfield for the overturn motor
vehicle with
injuries can you go address one more
time yeah I'm fine I'm fine I was going
straight and I don't know what happened
I'm sorry let me let me give back I have
a cop right here okay all right I love
you bye love
you I was going straight I don't know
what happened I was trying to go
straight I honestly don't know what 1 2
3 13 driving straight and then and when
you get a chance give
me that's about
it you talking yeah I was going to St
what
happened apparently they were pulling
out and I didn't see them I was just
going straight and apparent quite
flipped over I don't know what
happened you the
driver I was on straight I don't know
what happened I guess they were pulling
out but but I was going straight because
I had the right away and finally the car
I'm so
sorry
okay you're 450 certified um I'm
aania uh I what is your name Risa Raa
yes uh Raa were you drinking tonight I
was earlier yes when you say earlier uh
how much
earlier
uh
3:00 and how much did you have
by
here you're what fety mhm okay take her
off to the side the two of you yes sir
do what you do yes
sir I got to watch you minut yeah uh
Miss give us one
second um it's in a car me one second
just hold
it just hold it all like that we have
lighting yeah cuz I need to use this
line the only spot that has like that's
straight and
level what's your name Miss what's your
name Miss what's your name you can leave
your shoes there you you can leave your
Sho leave your shoes there what's your
namea
Raa okaya do you normally wear glasses
no I do you have contacts in your hand
in your eyes um do you have any medical
elements like you ever broke your
kneecaps broken legs nothing no no I I
do have a bad KN uh bad hip that's
nothing that can like stop me from
walking all
right can you see this tip of the pen
yeah all right so you're going to follow
the tip of the pen you're not going to
move your head it's only your eyes
following the tip of the pen all
right
uh things involve New Jersey don't move
your head you're going to follow the
pen your eyes your eyes are just going
to be the only thing moving you're doing
this you're doing it you can't move can
I P my pants up yeah yes yes yes
please cold as you are I'm sorry guys
it's okay it's okay just just listen to
the officer please
follow the tip of the pen just your eyes
don't move your head
okay sorry the the red lights are
like we're going to need a hook for the
uh Jersey PL I'll let you know you're
going to need a fact that this is going
have to be uh lifted off it
to let
me just look just look straight forward
this way all right don't look don't look
into the light
sorry I know don't look into the light
don't light
okay
actually hold it outside all right so
we're going to do a series of tests
you're going to follow my instructions
don't do anything until I tell you to do
so
okay so you're going to utilize this
line I'm just going to demonstrate on
this line so you can see what exactly
what I'm doing when I tell you to begin
you're going to stay in this position
okay you're going to put your left foot
out on the line left fo and then you see
this my back foot my big toe is going to
touch the heel in the back all right so
you start with your l y your you're
going to put your left foot out your
back right foot has to touch the back of
your heel and you're going to stay in
this position when I say begin you're
going to count out loud three four on
when you're ready you're going to count
out
loud one
two three and so forth up to nine then
you're going to take a small series of
steps to follow in a circle to get you
back into position and then you're
counting out loud one we said Till 9
right I'm sorry it's so cold pay
attention please I'm paying attention
but it's so close you you understood the
instruction I gave you okay n okay so
get into the position your hands have to
stay on each
side okay put your left foot out on the
line make sure your right foot the big
toes touching your
heel
okay all right and you'll be getting
no
one
8 9 and he said turn around at n right
yep I don't know how you WR I'm sorry
I'm I'm to get back into position
okay one
8 now we got one more test to do okay so
face me just relax right now so what
you're going to do now is you're going
to keep your hands to your side it's
basically about balance when I say start
you can pick whatever leg you want
whatever your most comfortable with
you're going to raise it six in off the
ground and you're going to count one
Mississippi two Mississippi three
Mississippi four Mississippi until I say
stop sir how many
Mississippi until I say
stop is it okay I'm is it okay if I have
guys me favor go across the
street you got to have your hands at
your sides man
keep them to your side it's only going
to it's not going to be that long I
promise I'm so sorry I'm so cold all
right keep them to your side pick
whatever leg you want and LIF it 6t uh 6
in off the ground and then start
counting ready go
ahead one little bit two three four I
have a I I have I have a broken uh HP
just to let you know five 6 7 8 9 10 the
side
please one more time
please one more
time the same yeah it could do whatever
like you want whatever you're comforable
just to let you know I I do have a
broken hip on my left but I will
definitely do whichever side whichever
side You' like whatever your com
whatever side you
want one two
s Turn Around for Me Miss turn turn turn
around can I
see
B uh give us a second we'll get it all
right Missy being placed under arrest
for driving while intoxicated 4-50 39
4-50
okay okay
okay I got
your let me get the light I
lock shortly all
right you have you have a
light
identification repeat
that
[Applause]
[Music]
all
right4 uh we're going to need more
manpower we got a 11025 this accident
for
450 driver's license right
here yeah
taking this all right
um another vehicle that's involved was
IL legally parked New Jersey Romeo
Michael whiskey 9 F
Echo get the get the U The
Flash need your technology B we go all
right
brother
good
of I need to free up our traffic us to
get them here we have one that's going
to be going to the medical center uh
shortly going to have 11025 as a result
of this I don't have my 11 I'm walking
to the car now so I can reach out to
Chief
GL
yeah we're definitely going to need
traffic un for
[Music]
this
see3 got a Lo coming down from the
hospital hit our
cars
um your car my car B uh my car's off the
corner all
right
123 whoa who scream
[Music]
so um
okay 23 Lieutenant
[Music]
Gonzalez I have Stevens on the phone do
you need assistance with traffic
anyway so if you got any calls for
service we can use them or set them to a
relieve uh Lo
um I'm see we our
traffic is going to bring her up
already I have a personal stuff what you
want me to do you want me to stand by
here with you uh no I can
hand gets up there uh safely and then
back I'll hand the all right go
ahead you need us whatever you need
we're
available
if you can uh free up our two units we
have one Traffic Unit over on detail at
the fire I need them here and the other
Traffic Unit is on Prison watch I need
in as well we'll handle the 2 and
the you got
it way down there
be
thanks
what
yeah yeah
yeah
oh
110 uh I'll be bringing up one female
105 along with uh
118 and uh starting m is 308 3.1
20 is on his
[Music]
way
for
274 I'm responding to the fire we
leaving all right Sergeant fal's down
there now you just Rel be if you want to
go Rel him
the
is that you6 to
was
yes 14 uh we'll be done here in a couple
minutes uh then you can come and block
uh Bloomfield
see I my car
down I'd rather you leave here
atfield
between the are leaving
now are you are you too
yeah
thank
you just have seat right now
yeah
wait I'm only say that
I okay I know it's
[Applause]
not
for
you